[Müzik]
çok güzel gözüküyorsunuz birinci soru
Evet biraz kilo verdim fotoğraftaki
arada bir 17,5 kilo kadar fark var
azimle devam ediyorum şu aramızda mutlu
olan var mı Onlar çıkabilir onlar olmuş
yani akşam oldu onlar olmuş Tamam ya biz
şimdi mutsuzlar mutlu olmaya çalışacağız
biraz bu ara ramizle konuştum ben tedeke
geldim yok mutlu olamadım yok şu olmadı
olmasın diye çıkışta Hasan size zanx
verecek zanı alıyorsunuz acemilere kadar
Bob Marley gibi gidiyorsunuz Ondan sonra
ne olur açıkçası çok bilmiyorum ama biz
Han Mutlu Olduk mu olduk şimdi az önce
Ahmet'le orada böyle fiskos fiskos
yaparken mutluluğun asında paylaşmak
olduğunu da bir anda hissettim Biraz
sonra paylaşımımda inanın mutlu
olmayacaksınız Ama mutluluk dediğimiz bu
keyif haline yeni bir anlam
yükleyeceksiniz ve 7 milyar tane var ya
bizden onlardan bir tanesini söylemeye
başlayacaksınız ben bu tip paylaşımlar
yaparken şu soruyla karşılaşıyorum ya
hayat bir şekilde akıyor
ne gerek var mutlu olmaya Eğer kilo
vermek
istiyorsan uzun yaşamak istiyorsan
meditasyon yapmak istiyorsan sevmek
sevilmek
istiyorsan torunlarına anlatacak
hikayelerin olsun
istiyorsan Geceleri rahat uyumak
istiyorsan evet mutlu olmak zorundasın
Ha bir de unutmadan toplu taşıma
araçlarında Vip hizmeti almak istiyorsan
mutlu olmak zorundasın Neden şu mutluluk
biraz gülümseme verir metrobüste
gülümseyin diyor ki yandaki Oğlum bu
manyak herhalde biraz Açılın filan
derken ben Mecidiye kadar VIP ile
gidiyorum böyle haf vallahi
yanınızdakiler böyle bir gülümseyin o
Vallahi bir şey oldu vallahi bir şey
oldu deyip böyle bir ilerleyecek Onun
için gerçekten mutlu olmanız çok önemli
Peki nedir bu mutluluk ya sürekli Ramiz
Ben kumandayı kaybettim diyordum
buradaymış hani sürekli mutluluk
mutluluk mutluluk Arkadaşlar biz bu
hayatta sadece mutlu olay sadece
mutluluk yok Hayat içerisinde acı
mutsuzluk keder üzüntü
Barındırır mutsuzluk mutluluk
barındırdığı gibi diğer olumsuz
duyguları da Barındırır ben er ya da geç
bu duyguyla karşılaşacağım er ya da geç
sevdiğim kişi tarafından terk edilece
Sevdiğim kişiyi kaybedeceğim mutsuz
olacağım er ya da geç kırılacağım
üzüleceğim darıa Yalnız kalacağım er ya
da geç
hayat mek istediği mesajı bana
hissettirecek ve ben bu hayat dediğim
yolculuk içerisinde devam edeceğim Ama
ben neden mutsuz oluyorum biliyor
musunuz Sürekli mutsuz
mutsuzluktan kaçınmak için mutsuz
oluyorum Mutluluktan kaçınmak için
mutsuz oluyorum yani şu Bursa'da kaç iki
tane FSM var biliyor musunuz FSM
Caddesi bilen var mı fsmi Bilen var mı
var mı var süper Peki ikincisinin nerede
olduğunu bilen var mı Şimdi benim için
bir mutluluk tanımı var ya O olmazsa
benim için mutluluk olmuyor Ben de
vazgeçiyorum Bursa'ya geldim Bir davete
katılacağım şimdi kestane şekeri
alamazsın cantık götüremezsin tahinli
götüremezsin o zaman ne yapacaksın
değişik bir şey olsun dedim yazdım o
navigasyon programına Butik
çikolata ben ulin oradayım 48
sonra mobilyalar nerede
satılıyordu Süper orada da bir tane FSM
var ve beni oraya götürdü Ve ben
mutlulukla gidiyorum Ne o Butik çikolata
alacağım FSM o o üst geçitten döndüm
köyün içine girdim kahvedekilere korna
çaldım çıktım İnegöl markete girdim
Selamünaleyküm Aleykümselam dayı dedim
buk çikolata var mı var yeyim dedi
çikolataları gösteriyor şimdi marka
vermeyeyim kırmızı olanı Dedim ki Dayı
şimdi Ben hala düşünüyorum arka tara
Butik çikolata üretiyorlar ön tarafta
böyle ufak ufak başka şeyler satıyorlar
ben onu arıyorum Hani beni oraya
götürmüş ya hani ben ona inanıyorum
çünkü Sonra bir baktım ki Dayı dedim
Daha şey Hindistan cevizi varmış yeğenim
orada çikolatalar diyor bir de sonra
arkadaşım aradı Neredesin İnegöl'de Ne
yapıyorsun butuk Çikolata arıyorum ben
Doğru bildiğim inandığım şeyin peşinden
koşacağım zaman mutlu olacağımı
zannettim ama mutluluk böyle var olmuyor
Öncelikle Az önce 50 tane güzel
arkadaşıma buradan teşekkür ediyorum
Ellerinize kollarınıza sağlık onlar size
bir şey sordu Ne için Mutsuzsun bakın
nedeni sorgulamıyorum Çünkü çünkü le
gelecek peşine Çünkü şöyle oldu çünkü
böyle oldu bakalım bakalım ister
misiniz
süper bunları Siz yazdınız çok
değerliler
sorumsuzluk
beni mutsuz ediyor Devam ediyorum
yalnızlık o iş bende merak etme tanıdık
var kanalın ismini vermeyeyim Ne Çıkarsa
Bahtına programın ismi Pazartesi
beğeniyorsun salı başka bir şey çıkıyor
ama bende sevgisiz
ortamlar plansızlık bak Hep başkasıyla
ilgili
boşluk
torpilim olsaydı şu anda burada olmazdım
Bu da beni çok mutsuz ederdi
enteresan Sen eski sevgilin mi burada
Ben mutsuz ediyormuşum H ok mutsuzluğu
süper bir şekilde tanımlıyoruz ama konu
mutlulukla ilgili bir şeyler söylemeye
başladığında bizim çok net yargılarımız
var ne olduğumu Kendime soruyorum ben
neyim algı yönetmeliğ böyle her her Ana
ana haber bülteninde bir kere söyleniyor
algı yönetmeniyim sonra DB pozitifi
bünyesinde senelerdir paylaşım yapan bir
eğitmenim Sizin gibi güzel insanlarla
tanışıyorum her gün sonra küçük
hikayelerimi paylaştığım bir de böyle
yazar çok e Üstat da burada çok şey
olmuyor ama hani yazar da bir kimliğim
var ne olduğumu biliyorum sorun benim
mutsuzluk o karmaşa endişe bir sürü
olumsuz şey gelecek ya Birazdan nereye
gittiğim le alakalı Nereye gidiyorsunuz
bu soruyu sorduğum zaman hocam emekli
olunca ben Datça'ya yerleşeceğim vallahi
Geçen hafta daç daydım yazlık var orada
hiç kimse yok Bursa taşımacılık filan
görmedim ben orada Pardon özuludağ
taşımacılık öyle bir şey olabilir yok Ne
yapıyorsun zihinle ruhun arasındaki
bağlantıyı kestin sonra sana dayatılan
mutlulukların
peşinden koşuyoruz mutluluk peşinden
koşul bir şey değil mutluluk
hissedilebilecek
şe soruyorum Nereye gidiyorsunuz aşka
giden var Sonra huzura giden var
Sonra yazlığa giden var şimdi sihirli
bir şey söyleyeyim mi size bugün yoksa
bu
anda anlam yoksa içinde mutluluk yoksa
var etmek için hiç çaba
göstermiyorsa 30 sene sonra o soru
işaretinin olduğu yerde mutlu
olmayacaksın çünkü daha önce
tanımlamadan bir şeyi nasıl fark
edebilirsin ki nasıl var edebilirsin ki
hayatında doğru mu peki ben o zaman Ana
anlam katmaya başlamam lazım mutluluk
dediğim her neyse size özel tanıma Peki
bunu nasıl yapacağım birkaç tane
paylaşım yapacağım sona Ama bu yolculuğu
ilerlemeniz çok önemli biz ne
yapıyoruz biz sürekli yeni Engeller Var
ediyoruz sürekli engellerimiz büyüyor
bakın Biz ların karşısında küçülüyoruz
işte engellerin nedenlerinden Birkaç
tanesini siz bana söylediniz Ne için bu
hayatta mutsuz olduğunu sen bana
söyledin hep onunla alakalı sen kendi
içinde var etmeyi Hiç düşünmedin Şimdi
size şunu soruyorum
Ellerim
Ellerimi gördüğüm için mi varlıklarını
kabul ediyorum yoksa görmeme gerek
olmadan sadece hissedebildiğim için mi
Bakın bu soruyu sorduğumda o Mutluluk
arayışı içerisinde karşıma küçük küçük
hikayeler
çıktı şimdi mühendis arkadaşlarım vardı
Az önce Eee onlarla böyle paylaşım
yaptık Mühendisler hep hemen şunu
soruyorlar bana hocam bunun form Siz
mühendis misiniz Evet değil misiniz öyle
bir duruş var ama yani mühendis duruşu
hocam makine iki terk filan Eyvallah
şimdi peki dedim ki yani bu formülize
edilsin paylaşıyoruz mutluluk
paylaşıyorsun algı paylaşıyorsun kenarda
köşede bir yerde yakılıyor diyor ki ya
Evren bir şey soracağım Efendim diyorum
ben ya Bu mutluluğun formülü varsa
Hayırdır diyorum Ne oldu Ya yengen çok
kızıyor da bana şimdi ben vereceğim
mutluluğun formülünü ki üstat vermiş
yazmış mutluluk eşittir gerçeklik eksi
beklentiler Einstein'in formülü ama bir
türlü bizde işe yaramıyor Çünkü bizim
kendi bahanelerimiz var o bahanelerin
arkasına saklanıyoruz Büyüyor büyüyor
işte Ben mühendisim anlamadım ben şöyle
ben böyleyim derken Bana bir tane bir
şey bekliyoruz ve o formül oturmadığı
müddetçe Ben yok oluyorum Aslı Aslı
hayatımda tanıdığım en mutsuz
insandı Aslı hayata kızgın Çünkü hayat
ondan en sevdiği varlığı olan annesini
almış 2 sene boyun 2 senedir Aslında
hayata kızgın bu hayatta nasıl mutlu
olabileceğim Evren diye soruyor bana
bende yok ki bilgi bende yok ki böyle
bir Sihir ne varsa sende var az önce
arkadaşımın yaptırdığı nefeste var ne
varsa o senin varlığını gösteriyor Bu
hayatta olduğunun en güzel kanıtı sonra
kocasına kızmış Niye Çünkü kocası ona
anne yaptı o istemiyordu sonra kızına
kızdı Neden Çünkü anne o da annesini
kaybedecek bir gün Aslı bu dünyadan
ayrılacak ya aslının çektiği acıları
çekmesin diye kızını sevmekten
vazgeçti Sadece bir şey sordum hayatında
senin hayatında şimdi Ase sorduğum şeyi
size de soruyorum senin hayatında değer
verdiğim tek bir şey var şurada Onu bir
düşün
istiyorum Aslı bu soruyu sordu Eşini
aradı Bu gece eve erken gel dedi Ferit
her akşam eve geç geliyor mesaiye
kalıyor Çünkü sevdiği kadını ağlarken
görmek istemiyor bundan yorulmuş
Ferit sabaha kadar konuşuyorlar
sarılıyor öpüşüyor ve diyor
ki ben senin için
buradayım
sabah kapının kapı açılmaya çalışıyor
çünkü her sabah kayın Mahallesi geliyor
kızı okula hazırlamak için Aslı kapıyı
açıyor anne Hoş geldin diyor çayı
demledim geç otur sen kahvaltıya Başla
ben de geliyorum kadın
şok sonra kızını okula hazırlıyor
servise götürüyor servise kapıya
servisin içine bırakıyor kız tekrar geri
koşuyor aslıya sarılıyor diyor ki Anne
yarın sabah da beni okula hazırlayacak
mısın asıl diyor ki evet yarın sabahta
öbür sabah da Allah bana Ömür verdiği
müddetçe Ben seni okula
hazırlayacağım Ben asıya şunu sordum var
olan
değerlerini başka şeyler için terk
ettin değersizliktir Belki de mutlus
kaynağı
Ben neden mutsuz oluyorum biliyor
musunuz o değerleri nasıl bir anda içini
boşaltıyorum şu şekilde hayatımdaki her
şeyden kaçınıyorum Artık her şeyden
kaçınıyorum tartıştığım zaman ilişkimden
kaçınıyorum
Eee neydi o pideli köftenin köftesi az
gelince oradan kaçınıyorum hep
kaçınıyorum kaçındığım zaman o
sorunların kaybolacağını düşünüyorum
kayb olmuyorlar onlar buraya daha fazla
yara açmaya devam
ediyor sonra kontrol etmeye çalışıyorum
bana dünyada kontrol edebildiğiniz tek
bir şey gösterin yok hiçbir şeyi kontrol
edemezsin Ama kontrol edemediğini
gördüğün anda buradaki Sen olan
özgüvenin zedeleniyor sen her geçen gün
böyle yürümeye başlıyorsun nasıl mutlulu
hissetmeyi var etmeye
çalışacaksın karşılaştırıyorum benim
elimdeki diplomayla seninkini seninkiyle
öbür künü derken hayatımda var olan
değer verdiğim her şeyi
karşılaştırıyorum ben yeni araba aldı
diye bir şey hissedemiyorum Eğer yandaki
komşudan daha yeni model değilse bana
mutluluk dendiği zaman çok çok enteresan
bir tanım yapıldı keyif hali bedenin
aldığı haz zihnin aldığı tatmin keyif ve
eylemlerin sonunda mutlu olacaksın dendi
bana Eğer böyle bir şey olsaydı o zaman
dünyanın en mutlu insanları madde
bağımlıları olması lazımdı devam his
sıkıntı yok doğru mu eylemin sonunda
mutluluk ama öyle bir şey değil işte bu
mutluluk
Ben mutluluğu
tanımlanamaz garip var Olup yok olan ama
hissedilmeye başlandığı an itibariyle
içinde bir şeyleri
değiştirdiğini inandığım iyi hissetme
hali olarak
tanımlıyorum ben en çok var olanı
kaybetmekten korkuyorum bu hayyatta
ölmekten korkmuyorum var olanı
kaybetmekten korkuyorum Onun için hazır
biraz da şu kadar olsun bir yerlerde var
olmaya çalışan mutluluk varsa onu biraz
yukarı çıkartmaya çalışın Peki Onu nasıl
yapacağım önce fark etmem lazım nelerin
beni mutsuz ettiğini fark etmem
gerekiyor neler beni mutsuz ediyor
bunları çok iyi tanımam gerekiyor sonra
yorumlamak acıyı mutsuzluğu mutsuzluğu
yaşama şeklinizi yorumlayın arkadaşım
dedi ki ya evrense 10 sene sevdiğim kız
beni terk etti nasıl yorumlayın acıyı
nasıl yaşama şeklini değiştireyim her
gece rakım asasında mış dedim ki
çikolataya Aç o kavanozu başla acıyı
yaşama şeklini değiştirmen lazım var
etmek çok önemli bana dediler ki Evren
mutluluğun peşinden Koş yakala bir
yerlerde onu kıır Mutluluk senin içinde
sende var olacak bir yerde dışarıdan
geldiği zaman inan İnan bana seni mutlu
etmiyor hayatında her zaman iyi
olmayacak Her zaman mutlu her zaman
mutsuz olduğun anlar da
olmayacak ama vazgeçmek yerine
ilerlemeye başladığın and anda inan bana
buradan bir şey taşıyacaksın ve o olumlu
Duygu olacak senin için Çünkü
ilerleyebilmek iyi gelir inanmak
inanmayı kastettiğim şey şu mutluluğa
inanmak mutluluğa mutlu olabileceğine
inanmak yoksa sen sadece olduğun yerde
beklersin kitaba ismini veren
arkadaşımla oturuyoruz Sanem 42 yaşına
gelmiş kafasını Çekyatın üstüne dayamış
elinde 5 kahvesi Evren sana evren'e
mesaj gönderiyorum almıyorsun dedi dedim
bana mesaj falan gelmiyor dedi ki ben de
dalga geçme Ne istediğimi biliyorsun
Evren aşık olmak istiyorum Salonda
pijamalarla mı bu şekilde gönderdiği
mesajla Vek Selahattin abi gelir
apartman görevlisi O da öğlen çöp var mı
yenge
diye zaman zaman Bursa olduğumu
hissediyorum kan çekiyor Bu tarafa doğru
şükretmek Şükür içinde teşekkür
Barındırır teşekkür etmeye başladığınız
zaman aradığınız o tek değeri mutlulu
edecek mutluluğu var edecek değeri
keşfetmeye
başlayacaksınız hayatınızda şükr
ettiğiniz 3 tane şey deyince hemen
sayacaksın Oğlan ev eşim kaynanam
diyen 5 10 100 ama bir gün içinde
yaşadığınız değerlere bir
bakın nasıl O nasıl olacak O nasıl var
olacak arkadaşlar
mutluluk Böyle kısır tanımla bir iki
şeyle anlatılabilecek bir duygu değil
mutluluk Çok derinde var olabilen bir
duygu Sende bir yerlerde var olabilen
bir
duygu önce kendine sonra yaşadığın Bu
dünyaya bir iyilik yapmak istiyorsan ilk
önce kendinde mutluluğu var etmeye sonra
mutluluk arayışı içinde olan diğer
insanlarla bunu
paylaşmaya özen göster Çünkü mutluluk
burada var olur burayı etkiler ve tüm
dünyaya dağılır beni davet ettiğiniz
için paylaşımda bana da yer verdiğiniz
için çok teşekkür ediyorum kendi
mutluluk tanımama bir şey daha yaptım bu
güzel yüzlerdeki o duyguyu alıp bir de
bir hanımefendi geldi az önce böyle yani
Yanaklarımı sıkacak sıkamadığımız
önüme kulanı yerim çok güzel dedikodu
kanın programından hiç canım sıkılmaz
bakkala da ekmek almaya gidip gelirim
şimdi bir mutluluk egzersizi için sizi
ayağa alabilir miyim lütfen hadi bir
egzersizi birlikte yapalım Çok basit
bizim Trakya'da böyle düğünlerde
kınalarda dedeler vardır biliyor musunuz
onlar böyle 8 buç gibi çıkarlar gece
12'ye kadar dans ederler ne zaman
kendini biraz Kötü
hissediyorsan O hayatın mutsuzluk
dediğin kısmı sana geliyorsa İnan bana
inan bana değerin seni daha mutluluğu
değerin senin mutluluğunu var etmek için
sana iyilik yapmaya devam edecek ve sen
iyi hissedeceksin çok basit bu çalıyor
mu
Süpersin elleri bir görebilir
miyim Bundan sonrası
sizde
Çıldır Çıldır Çıldır salla kolları salla
kolları hadi hi hi hi hi hi karanlık çok
güzel seni kimse görmüyor
ha Harikasınız Çok teşekkür ediyorum
Eyvallah çok teşekkür ediyorum Eyvallah
Eyvallah çok teşekkür ediyorum
Eyvallah bu
arada öer
lüy
klt başladı Harikasın y burada onun için
karanlıktı hiç gözükmedi hiç merak etme
çok teşekkür
ediyorum